it was a night of revelry that quickly
turned into a tragedy desperate scenes
as First Responders and other
party-goers attempted to resuscitate
victims pulled from the Crush packed
with crowds people converged on this one
Alleyway with deadly consequences
we came here around 10 pm and it was
like a scene from a movie like things
happening during a war it was completely
out of control
some of the first Rescuers at the scene
said they couldn't get the injured to
hospital because of the crowds many of
whom didn't realize the tragedy that was
unfolding
there were too many people and it was
too crowded I know the police and rescue
workers are working hard but I would say
there was a lack of preparation
Sunday morning Seoul woke up to the
enormity of this tragedy as an
investigation gets underway into how it
happened as the bar and entertainment
districts of Seoul itaewan is normally
busy at Halloween but with pandemic
restrictions being lifted for the first
time these streets were filled with tens
of thousands of partygoers
with some of the Wounded suffering
severe injuries the death toll is likely
to rise
with most of the victims in their 20s or
even teens Rob McBride Al Jazeera Seoul